Does that look okay?
Brexit would have a big impact on both the
world economy and the United States economy.
Not simply would we have Britain,
which is the world's fifth largest economy
doing very poorly
but rather because Britain will have a contagion
effect on the European economy, which is a
very large partner of the United States.
Brexit is also likely to lead to a Sterling
crisis that could fan currency wars at
a time that the Bank of Japan and the European
Central Bank are trying to cheapen their currencies.
The United States would be impacted not simply
by a slowing European economy, but by a financial
crisis globally, that could be a strong headwind
to the United States economy.
Sadly, there's very little that the United
States can do to affect this result, other
than to hope that the British have got the
good sense to vote "No" against Brexit.
Please let us know in your comments how you
think Brexit might affect the world's economy
and also let us know what other topics you'd
like us to discuss in 60 seconds on this and
other issues.